Aaron Carter just asked Chloe grace
Moretz out twice hi friends this is the
daily Deni and its new music Friday
we've got those tracks for you at the
end of the show plus we're giving away
an official gift back from the Teen
Choice Awards so stick around to find
out how you can enter but first could
love blossom between a former it boy and
Hit Girl if Aaron Carter has his way the
answer is yes the singer is freshly
single after a breakup with former
girlfriend Madison Parker and publicly
made a move on young Hollywood star
Chloe grace Moretz slice Chloe revealed
she had a childhood crush on the
longtime heartthrob she revealed that
she and her friend used to fight over
Carver's potential affection when they
were just four years old well Carter
caught wind of that and took to social
media to ask her out in two separate
tweets saying mmm may I take you to
dinner Chloe Moretz and hey Chloe Moretz
let's set up a date the crush is mutual
you know that second was accompanied by
a smiley heart emoji so you know the
crush is like serious so far there's
been no response from Miss Moretz but
trust we will be tracking the situation
as it develops and you can count on an
update as soon as we have one now Erin's
thirst is real but you know what so is
mine yesterday million dollar Matchmaker
Patti Stanger gave her a hot take on
some of Hollywood's hottest couples but
let me tell you the tables were turned
on me when I asked her for some dating
advice and I was all ears the rule of
thumb for people like me who are looking
for love on the app okay I think because
you how old are you like under 33 yeah
you're just under 30 you need to take
your time and use just have fun I know
engage on we hit it to quit it but if
you want a serious relations is we lose
interest when we have sex so fast we got
to get to know someone drink okay I just
feel like it's not really it's not a
good thing like I have a lot of gay
friends and they're all like we'll have
to try them out I'm like can you try
them out when you're in sober at lunch
and you get so much and you're not
sitting at the Abby and my hobbies right
now I'm a hopeless romantic I'm all
about the dating
ya know the peace right we are super
cute so I'm making my look I want to
tell the people Pat Thank You patty but
you know what I am a mess I literally
just found that one of my buttons is a
button TV folks or the internet well if
that doesn't work out I'm just going to
tweet my sled crushes speaking of
Channing Tatum how you doing Batman is
busy promoting his new movie
Logan lucky but hijack the traditional
press tour and instead hit the road
making pit stops across the country to
promote it and earlier this week one
lucky gas station attendant by the name
of Beatrice got the surprise of her life
when Magic Mike himself popped in for an
impromptu dance party
get it Beatrice that right there is
carpe diem seize the moment let me tell
you the moment was not lost on chaining
either here's what he told ET about his
new boo Beatrice I was afraid to choose
me get fired if I stayed any longer like
like what when this goes on printer that
over town I don't see the control over
this is like fan and money around I love
her man all right that little gas
station party was cute Jenny but let's
be real it was not Joe Manganiello you
guys remember this clip from Magic Mike
double XL uh-huh yeah come through Joe
mm-hmm aquafina didn't see what was
coming are you guys it is new music
Friday so here the jam to set you right
this weekend starting with marshmallow
featuring two leads this is silent
[Music]
[Music]
those two are all the way up but if
you're looking at your summer with a
more low-key banger and look no further
than Wiz Khalifa and Ty dolla sign's
something new gimme some
[Music]
Betty company stuff cuz I can toss up if
I gotta take dial up baby come to me
something mm-hmm and if you think that
sexy
wait until you see fifth Harmony's video
for their new single angel
[Music]
[Applause]
okay clearly those girls are now grown
alright five HR not expected at this
Sunday's Teen Choice Awards but looking
for you guys we are giving away a piece
of Teen Choice swag this is the contents
of the official gift bag which features
a watch some earbuds this dope jacket
from West Coast vibes we got the back
massager Mike and Ikes Jenga
boppy I mean everything and did I
mention a stay at a resort in Costa Rica
that's right you can enter for your
chance to win by heading over to ET
online.com
giveaways you must be 18 and over and
you have until midnight Pacific on
Monday to enter are you guys good luck
and have a great weekend look I massage
my back yeah oh